what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the Fantastic Four now
some of what we're going to talk about
in this video in the beginning will be
important maybe to a degree later on
everything in the second half is
ridiculously important and it's amazing
at the same time okay so here's the
thing what this does is this initially
opens up with basically Reed Richards
addressing what's called The Singularity
project and the whole idea behind this
is that Reed Richards had formed this at
a previous point in time to bring
together the world's brightest Minds
right the most most intelligent
individuals for solving various problems
the issue with this is it's kind of like
the uh Sir Ken Robinson lecture right
where he talked about how the biggest
issue with education in the modern era
is that it strips individuals of
creativity and it replaces it with logic
and reason which is not an inherently
bad thing but that lack of balance is
what really prevents Humanity from
achieving incredible things and that's
read Richard's stance here that as time
has gone on he's become disillusioned
with the singularity project because
instead of focusing on things of like
what Humanity can do reaching for the
stars and like colonizing the solar
system and so on and so forth these
individuals are using their intelligence
to write articles and talk about the
impending end of humanity overpopulation
economic inequality different things
along those lines and in the mind of
Reed Richards while those things are
relatively important the reality here is
that Reed Richards thinks beyond the
average person right a small-minded
person thinks in a small-minded way and
so they focus only on Humanity in
relation to its existence on Earth what
read Richards wants is a group that can
focus on Humanity in relation to
extending beyond that right like a
small-minded person is worried about
today a big-minded person is worried
about tomorrow and that's really what he
what he tells them here right you all
you're all small people because you all
think small this entire thing is a
failure and so he ultimately ends up
resigning and walking away what he does
instead is he comes to this realization
the ability to think outside the box
right that it really does come from kids
it's the example of the elephant in the
refrigerator if any of you guys ever
heard heard that that story was
basically this guy who essentially
started going around to like adults and
kids and trying to discern the
difference between like creativity and
kind of building off the studies of Sir
Ken Robinson regarding like education
and his failures and so on so what he
would do is he would walk up to adults
and he would say I want to put an
elephant in a refrigerator what do I do
and the adults would say things like
well you shrink the elephant down or you
make a gigantic refrigerator then you
could fit the elephant in but the kids
would say things like lure it in there
with a piece of cheese or something like
that or put a mouse behind it and scare
it in or just push it in but kids would
not give any thought to the logistics of
how to physically fit an elephant into a
refrigerator they would just think of
how it could be done and that ability to
think outside the box is what makes kids
unique and that's what Reid Richards is
shooting for right again small-minded
adults big-minded kids so what he ends
up doing is forming the Future
Foundation which is basically the
world's smartest kids because they can
think outside the box they can think in
a way that adults simply just can't do
because adults are Guided by their own
experiences right so a cynical adult
will write a series of cynical articles
no matter how intelligent they are and
so this gives birth to the formation of
the Future Foundation and that's the
Future Foundation part of this story
everything else is just like really cool
stuff that happens okay so here's the
thing one of the first things that
happens here and it's not even a really
significant moment but it's kind of a
cool small little moment and this is
this is important for a couple different
reasons one is because of the nature of
Franklin Richard's Powers but the other
is the relationship between Franklin and
Reed that what you have here is an
instance where there's like this big toy
event that's going to be put on by a
villain named arcade but Reed was
supposed to take Franklin and his friend
leech Reed ultimately reneges on his
promise in order to work with the Future
Foundation now Reed's there with
Franklin but he doesn't pay a lot of
attention to him he doesn't really focus
on him and that's going to be an on
running theme especially when Galactus
comes to visit Reed madder than he's
ever been in his full life and then they
talk about Franklin because the reality
here in a little bit of a spoiler for
this with Franklin Powers being woken up
it scares the piss out of Galactus it's
amazing it's just one of those
ridiculously awesome moments of the
comic it's God it's so cool when they
have that conversation but the thing
about
that reads and eggs on his promise
Johnny Storm ends up taking Franklin
instead now when they get there of
course Johnny recognizes arcade arcade
has historically been a villain that
basically creates death traps death
mazes Johnny's kind of suspicious of all
of this arcade has sort of turned over a
new Leaf to a degree but he's also
working with impossible man now we do
have a video of beyond omega level video
on impossible man this guy's
ridiculously powerful he can take on the
shape of virtually anything he wants and
give himself virtually any superhuman
power there are limitations so if he
turns himself into like Thor's hammer
for example he doesn't take on the
ability of Thor's hammer to only be
lifted by those who are worthy any swing
and Dick can just pick it up you know
you know what I mean so like that's kind
of how it works with impossible man but
the guy's just ridiculously op he is by
all Sanders of measurement Marvel's
version of Mr Mitchell pitlick for those
of you guys who are coming from DC
Comics so the thing about this is that
it's really just kind of them working
together to a degree in arcade kind of
turning over a new Leaf but also setting
up like a little bit of a death trap
where he tries to mess with the mess
with impossible man things kind of pop
off to a degree but what ends up
happening is that Franklin basically
dealing with this in the moment the toys
of Mr impossible which were created as
death traps by Arcade those are
destroyed by Johnny Storm the reason why
this is important for Franklin is
because the last time we saw him use his
powers he had created like a pocket
Universe in his bedroom now his powers
are more fine-tuned he brings a stuffed
dinosaur to life which attacks arcade
now it's not the most important thing
and it's not the most grand display of
Franklin's Powers but what I hope you
guys notice here is he's gaining more
control over his abilities and there's a
reason for that and we'll talk about
that during the actual Future Foundation
comic book run because there comes a
point where what John of the Hickman
does is like we'll cover the next story
arc for Fantastic Four which is called
three which is amazing but what that
does is it switches over to What's
called the Future Foundation and that
will actually explore how Franklin has
learned to master his abilities which is
really cool it's a really really cool
run but the important thing here is that
what this does is of course it allows
them to kind of save the day and and
sort of go forward from there but
another thing that's not important at
the moment but will become important
later is that read Richard to kind of
open the floor to the Future Foundation
to give them like their first real task
right their first real group project the
end result of their group project was
finding a way to cure Ben grimp now they
can't do it permanently and in fact they
actually outsmarted Reed Richards where
what Reid tried to do was revert Ben
Grimm back to his human form but what
they realized is because Ben Grimm had
been fundamentally changed due to his
exposure to the cosmic rays and the
Fantastic Four's origin that Reed
Richards can stretch Susan storm can
create force fields and make herself
invisible Johnny Storm can set himself
on fire but they do that because they
have basically an on off switch they can
use their powers or not use their powers
Ben Grimm is in a perpetually on switch
so what they do is they give him a
temporary off switch one week every year
he can go back to being human the funny
thing about this and what's really crazy
is that there's actually going to be a
caveat to this and it's not even
something anybody here can predict and
in fact it's going to be something that
by the time they realize what's going on
really read himself by the time he
realizes the caveat to this kind of cure
it'll be too late to do anything about
it it's actually really sad but really
happy at the same time it's kind of an
emotional rollercoaster to a degree but
of course they end up presenting him
basically with this formula and that's
basically it now this is when we switch
over to the really really cool stuff
okay so what we do here is we switch
over to what is basically adult Franklin
Richards if you guys recall in our
previous videos we had talked about how
this guy had appeared out of nowhere and
basically went into the Baxter building
woke up Franklin's Powers had a
conversation with Valeria and then left
so this is where he comes back to right
this is him coming back to his own to
wherever it was that he was at and in
reality it's at the very end of time
what they're in is basically a kind of
pocket reality that Franklin Richards
himself made as an adult so we're
basically dealing with two versions of
Franklin there's the adult Franklin
Richards which we're talking about here
then there's of course the kid Franklin
Richards in the present ERA this adult
Franklin is at the very into the time
stream at the very end of all things and
what he says is okay I completed my
mission I did exactly what I was
supposed to do at which point it's now
Valeria's turn to jump into the time
stream but the other thing that goes on
here is that once Valeria takes off
Franklin actually starts building a kind
of dimensional barrier quite literally
the powers of Franklin Richards at this
point in time are so astronomically
powerful he can actually hold off the
universe itself the entire universe
collapsing on itself or at least a kind
of cascading time stream where things
are changing and somebody being able to
hold all that off so this is an insane
level of power right and here's a crazy
thing it's not even as powerful as he's
going to be he's going to become more
powerful as time goes on it's nuts
that's why I tell you guys man dude
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four sun
sun it's a whole different thing but
what's crazy is that Franklin kind of
doing this on his own he's literally
here while you end up having Nathanael
who jumps back into the time stream as
well of course Nathaniel Richards being
the father of Reed yes he's here we'll
find out what he's been doing in this
video but one of the other things that I
also want you to kind of keep in the
back of your head in this moment here
where Franklin's in this place by
himself this is going to tie into the
Future Foundation comic so that's
something that I want you to just
remember here what we end up doing is
actually jumping back to the College
Years of Reed Richards that's where
Nathaniel Richards goes right he goes
back to the years when Reed was in
college now the funny thing about this
is that this was actually something that
was covered in Fantastic Four issue
number 272 is actually being changed
here a little bit by Jonathan Hickman so
you can kind of ignore that original
story all of you guys who are super old
school reading the Fantastic Four from
way back then if you're new to Fantastic
Four it doesn't matter to you right so
don't worry about that but the thing
about this is that of course Reed meets
with his father and again the last time
that Reid saw Nathaniel was when we
covered the the time that Nathaniel left
here in our Fantastic Four coverage on
Comics explained that's the last time
we've seen him when he was a little kid
and so seeing his father again is cool
and there's a lot of catching up to do
and he's like how in the world did you
like what have you been doing all this
time what's been going on now this is
cool because this is when we start
getting into this stuff with King to
conquer one of the things that I want to
establish here and I want to make clear
as you guys probably noticed King the
conqueror's name is Nathaniel Richards
this guy's name is Nathaniel Richards no
they are not the same person it's
literally just Nathaniel Richards came
to conqueror inheriting his name in the
same way that I am Robert Jefferson III
right my dad was a junior my granddad
was a senior right it's just that kind
of a thing so what is up going on here
is we end up learning that when when
Nathaniel took off into the time stream
it was because he was kind of part of
his own Council of reads to a degree and
what had been going on here is that
there was a member of himself one of
those guys out there who had basically
contained Quantum energy to a degree
right the ability to navigate through
time it ended up taking the combined
efforts of the various nathaniels from
across the Multiverse to bring this guy
down but when he was destroyed they were
all basically imbued with his ability to
travel through time what ended up
happening here is when that happened
they were all basically met by immortus
and the time variance Authority now for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with this immortus is a version of Kang
it's ridiculously confusing it's overly
complicated if you guys are interested I
can make a video that explains the
differences between Kane the Conqueror
immortus Rama Tut iron lad I can do that
if that's what you guys want if you
think it'll make it easier for you to
understand and honestly it'll probably
help given the fact that we're getting
Kang in the MCU we may end up seeing
some of those characters but the thing
about this is that immortus is just
basically a version of Kane the
Conqueror is really all it is he doesn't
share the same desire to conquer
everything he just kind of oversees the
time stream but what he realizes is that
again with the TVA trying to ensure that
the time stream doesn't spin out of
chaos and so on and so forth having
thousands of individuals who were all
just variants of themselves being able
to jump around the time stream would
create all kinds of chaos and so what
immortus does is he says either I can
destroy all of you now or you can go
into the great hunt and what that will
do is it's literally all of you cracking
each other down and the last man
standing is the one who gets to live and
that's it and that's what happens
literally it's a cat and mouse game
they're chasing each other all
throughout the time stream trying to
kill each other right trying to
eradicate each other and that's
literally what Nathaniel's been dealing
with he's just been running from all of
his counterparts this entire time and
there's only one counterpart left
there's only one version of himself that
exists out there and so what he's
literally done here is come and meet
Reed for the purpose of having Reed help
him destroy his counterpart now of
course Reed realizes he can't do it on
his own and so what he does is he goes
and he visits his College rival who we
know to be Victor Von Doom Doctor Doom
now this is before he becomes Doctor
Doom right before he gets his face is
all scarred and he becomes like the
demigod dictator ruler warlord amazing
one-line Giver to all of us right that
guy
the guy who delivers the best one-liners
ever and so with them working together
again we're kind of fast tracking
through this a little bit so we can get
to the really cool stuff but what they
do is they basically work together and
they ultimately end up tracking down the
counterpart version of Nathaniel himself
now the reality here is they're able to
overcome this guy is kind of what we
would expect they're able to overcome
and overpower this dude take him out
quite readily the thing about this
though is that Nathaniel cannot bring
himself to kill his counterpart and so
what ends up going on here is Doctor
Doom does it instead now this is
important because what Dr Doom says is
he tells Reed and he tells Nathaniel I
want you to remember this moment because
a time will come when I will call on you
for a favor I will call on you for help
and you will help me because I helped
you here because I literally solved this
problem for you that's going to become
stupendously important and so what ends
up happening is you basically have
Nathaniel who teleports away to meet
back with Franklin again now this is
when we get to the super important stuff
and this is when this leads into what's
arguably not even arguably definitively
not objectively into the best moment
ever in the history of Marvel Comics
Sansa it's like man I can't wait until
we get to it oh my God it's just like
the best moment ever oh my God like I'm
sorry I'm so excited people but it is an
exciting point in this story it is
really amazing
and I love it so much okay so what we
end up doing is we switch over to
Valeria Richards right when Valeria
travels back to the present day and
meets with Susan now I want you to
remember this conversation this is going
to be incredibly important later on so
what ends up happening here is Valeria
teleports to Susan Susan doesn't know
it's Valeria right it's a Time condition
red right somebody's literally entry in
the Backstreet building through the time
stream and Susan attacks Valerian now
right off the bat Valeria is just like
okay Mom let me have some of that tea
and that's when Susan realizes it's
Valeria so the two of them start talking
here right this conversation's so
awesome because what happens is that
there's a little bit of you know kind of
like hey mom you look great it's awesome
to see you again wow Valeria you really
grew up and you know you look beautiful
as a young woman and so on and so forth
right all that kind of hey we're getting
to know each other and then Susan asked
the question why are you here now this
explanation from Valeria happened at the
same time that Nathaniel basically
travels back to Franklin now for what
Franklin does here and this is something
that's kind of important we'll talk
about that here in a sec second what
Valeria says is this right she says it
would be best if you did not view me as
the bearer of bad news what I'm going to
tell you is not subjective mother it's
not a potential course of action it's
already happened right and more
importantly there's nothing you can do
to change it so it's crucial that you
get past denial and simply focus on
listening and she says will you do that
for me and the response to Susan is yes
and so what Valeria says here is she
says after the last war when all reality
has collapsed into a single time stream
and the heat death of everything is
imminent there is a white space where
your son sits waiting for the new future
we've created to overtake him their post
collapse he acts as an anchor for the
changes he's made and when I return to
him I will serve that very same function
regarding mon we cement this new future
that we have created with sacrifice
mother Franklin and I will die doing
this and so Susan immediately is like no
I can't accept this I won't because
she's literally being told by her
daughter me and your son are going to
die but again she you know responding
the way that a mother would that's when
Susan steps in and she says no you have
to focus you have to put your emotions
to the side here you can't focus on
denial you can't focus on trying to stop
this it doesn't work that way right
however there is a chance to save us
right she says we're running out of time
and you have to focus there are things
you need to know and literally Susan
interrupts her right and she's like how
do you even know that what you're doing
will work but you're just like your
father thinking you can solve everything
and the responsible Valeria is actually
no right she says I'm probably one of
the smartest people that has ever lived
but this was not my idea it was all
Franklin's idea he's the one that
figured it out and so Valeria says
time's almost up she says I don't want
you to do what it is that you're going
to do her response the responsible area
is it's already done and now for the
knowledge right this is the part that's
going to be ridiculously important
because this is going to be echoed at a
future point in time when she says the
coming days are going to be dark dark
and full of loss it will feel like
everything is going to break apart that
it will shatter and everything will end
as she says only you can hold us
together can you be strong mother
stronger than you've ever been before
there will be a moment when you're going
to want to give up a moment when you're
going to want to let go when you reach
that point look into the sky look up and
remember the price that was paid that is
going to be incredibly important because
the best moment ever in Marvel Comics is
when that's ever when that's going to
come back anybody who knows anything
about Jonathan was Fantastic Four y'all
know what I'm talking about son son son
y'all know what I'm talking about man I
can't wait to eat
can't wait till we get to that point man
man it's gonna be absolutely crazy son
it's gonna be absolutely crazy now as
for Franklin this is what was going on
with Nathaniel right once Nathaniel
jumps back to where Franklin is and
Franklin asks him did you take care of
your counterpart the response to
Nathanael is yes and Franklin's like
good he cracks a hole in the time stream
and tries to dump Nathaniel through it
now Nathaniel does not initially know
why Franklin's doing this right he's
like he's like why are like what are you
doing why are you doing this and I can't
use my Powers I can't travel through
time the response of Franklin is I shut
off your access to your powers I took
away your ability to use your powers I'm
gonna dump you into the time stream and
who knows where you're going to end up
but I'm pretty sure you'll find a way or
you'll find some way to survive and some
way to return quite literally what
Franklin's doing is removing Nathaniel
from the equation and when the questions
asked by Nathaniel why are you doing
this the response to Franklin is because
you and your and your your variants that
are out there you're responsible for the
Council of reads you're the ones who
made them and you're the one who broke
my dad the reality is all those
different versions of Reed Richards who
were out there in the Multiverse to join
the Council of REITs it was so easy for
them to abandon their families and focus
on solving the problem of everything
because you abandoned them I don't want
you hopping and skipping to the timeline
and screwing everything up I have a very
meticulously laid plan on how this is
going to work and you are too much of a
variable to allow you to run around and
do anything you can't stay here because
then you'll try to move around or
something like that and I need to be
here for my own particular purpose and
you can't be moving through the time
stream so literally he just shuts off
his powers kicks him out and he just
ends up Landing somewhere out there in
the time stream now the cool thing about
this is we're actually going to see
we're going to we're going to learn
about Nathaniel encountering some
amazing time streams along the way like
he ends up coming across Days of Future
Past but what ends up happening is once
Valeria comes back she's like okay is
everything done and the response of
Franklin is yes Nathaniel is no longer
part of the equation he's out there in
the time stream who knows where what
he's doing and he probably won't be able
to you won't be able to gain or use his
powers in any capacity because I shut
them off and so what they say is okay
because like what's literally happening
right now is this pocket reality that
Franklin's built it's collapsing right
like the pressure of the universe in the
time stream is simply too much that as
powerful as he is in being able to hold
it off he can't hold it off permanently
and so what they're hoping for right and
the actions that they've taken what
they're hoping for is this right using
the example that we use in the king the
Conqueror video right where we talked
about like a meteor hitting Earth and
like a tidal wave them going back in
time and basically making these changes
having these discussions saying these
things that is creating changes to the
time stream and what they're hoping and
there's no way to even know for sure if
it's going to work what they're hoping
is that this quote-unquote tidal wave of
change across the time stream once it
hits them and washes over when they jump
into the time stream and they land in
the present day they're hoping it worked
they're hoping that their statements and
their actions were heard and that they
can save the day and so literally what
they do right this this is this is
ridiculous mostly important what they do
is they jump into the time stream where
they come out if you've read Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four before you know
exactly where they come out they come
out at the best moment ever in the
history of Marvel Comics I can't wait
until we get there we'll get there soon
probably in the next few weeks I know a
lot of you guys are like no I want to
know now I promise it's worth the wait
because the next story we cover that's
when one of the members of the Fantastic
Four dies this guy goes out like like a
like a man oh my god dude this guy goes
out like a hero it's absolutely amazing
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later peace